Hey everyone, my name is Tyler Oakley...
...and this is my life.
I was born March 22nd 1989 in Jackson, Michigan at Foote Hospital.
My parents were divorced when I was a toddler...
...so I've always had two families.
Between my sisters and my stepbrothers and my stepsisters...
...and my half-brother and my in-laws, I have 12 siblings total.
In elementary school, I had to get glasses...
...so my parents let me pick out whatever pair I wanted.
So, I got these big round glasses that were bright purple.
It was basically the start of my fabulosity.
Back then, I began to develop a bit of an addictive personality.
No matter what it was that I was obsessed with,...
...I had to have everything involved with it.
When it was pogs, I had my own pog maker.
When it was Beanie Babies, I had tag protectors and value handbooks.
When it was Pokemon, I competed at local video game stores and tournaments.
I guess that's why nowadays I can't get off Tumblr.